NARRATOR: The following content
is provided under a
Creative Commons License.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, so this takes us
into the paper by Heitler
and London, where, by using
the concept of linear
combination of atomic orbitals
into molecular orbitals for a
large number of atoms, instead
of splitting one plus one
atoms, making a bond into two
energy levels of bonding and
AN antibonding, we take a large
number of atoms, bring
them together, and we get a
large number of bonding
orbitals and a large number
of antibonding orbitals.
And they have to lie within a
zone of about 5 to 10 electron
volts, which means if you put
Avogadro's number of these
things together, you're going
to end up with an energy
difference between successive
energy levels on the order of
about 10 to the minus 20
electron volts, or 10 to the
minus 40 joules.
And for all intents and
purposes, that is a continuum,
and hence, the term band.
And now we start populating this
with electrons, and each
one of these is a
separate state.
And electrons go in two by two,
just like Noah's Ark, all
the way up-- either halfway
up or all the way up.
But now the energy difference
is very, very tiny.
And a second instance, we looked
at insulators where--
for example, in diamond--
where the bonds are
really strong.
So that means if the atomic
orbital is roughly at the
middle here, the depression to
make the bonding orbital is
very, very great, and
very negative.
And therefore, the elevation to
the antibonding orbital is
great and relatively positive.
And when we start putting
Avogadro's number of these
things together, we still
end up with the 10 to
the minus 40 joules.
But when we get to the top of
the bonding orbitals, we have
still got 3 or 5 or 5 electron
volts to get to the bottom of
the antibonding orbitals, hence
the formation of the
band gap with an energy of--
as I mentioned.
So up here, we have the
conduction band where
electrons are free
to move about.
And this is derived from the
antibonding orbitals.
And down here, we have the
valence band, which consists
of the bonding orbitals derived
from sigma and pi.
And then the semiconductor is
sort of like an insulator--
as they say in California, it's
like an insulator-- but
the band gap isn't
quite so severe.
It's down on the order of 1 to
3 electron volts, and that
gives it unique properties.
Why?
What's magical about 1
to 3 electron volts?
Number one, visible light.
Visible light is 2 to
3 electron volts.
So visible light shines right
through an insulator, because
visible light has an energy of
about 2 to 3 electron volts.
If that's the energy of 2 to 3
electron volts, and this is 6,
it zooms right through.
But if it's 2 electron volts and
this is 1 electron volt,
we're going to get thermal
excitation.
I know Professor Ballinger
talked about thermal
excitation the last day and what
happens, and it's very
reminiscent of excitation in
the case of the Bohr model.
Photoexcitation across
the band gap.
Incident photon with energy
greater than the
energy of the band gap.
And it's the same drill
as you've seen before.
That's why those early
lessons on--
photon comes in or electron
comes in, strikes the Bohr
atom, electron rises up,
momentarily sits there, falls
back down, photon emitted.
It's the same set of ideas.
Only instead of moving from n
equals 1 to n equals 2 in the
Bohr atom, you're moving from
the valence band to the
conduction band, sitting
in the conduction band
momentarily, you fall back
down, and you get a
photoemission.
So that was covered last day.
And I know towards the end of
the lesson, he started talking
about thermal excitation.
So let's look at that in
a little more detail.
Thermal excitation.
So thermal excitation of what?
Thermal excitation of electrons
across the band gap.
So this is matter energy
interaction, only in this
case, it's thermally inspired.
So let's draw our
cartoon again.
Up here, we have the conduction
band, and below we
have the valence band.
So in the conduction band
we have free electrons.
In the valence band is where
all the bonds live.
And we've got an energy gap
here of some value.
Could be semiconductor,
could be insulator.
In this case, we're going
to use visible light.
And we've gone through the
analysis with incident photon
and the emission.
In this case, I want to look
at thermal excitation.
So with thermal excitation, I
start with an electron down
here in a bond.
This electron lives in a bond.
And with thermal excitation, the
electron jumps out of the
bond and up into the
conduction band.
So I'm going to designate the
electron in the conduction
band with an e minus and
a circle around it.
And it leaves behind
a broken bond.
As you know, every bond has
two electrons in it.
Well, one of the electrons left
the bond, leaving a hole.
Little h with a plus sign.
This is a broken bond, and a
broken bond is highly unstable
and very mobile.
If I put a potential
across here.
If I put this material-- and I'm
doing a mixed metaphor--
this is an energy
level diagram.
But now I'm going to put a
couple of plates across an
energy level diagram.
But you're smart.
You can understand this.
So this is not energy.
Now I'm going to make the right
electrode negative and
I'm going to make the left
electrode positive.
What would happen?
Well, the electrons in the
conduction band are going to
be attracted to the positive
electrode or repelled by the
negative electrode, but the
complementary situation occurs
in the valence band.
This broken bond is like a
hot potato, and it has an
effective charge.
This is a zero in a
land of minus one.
A broken bond is a zero in
a land of minus one.
So therefore, if I make the
right side negative, this hole
is going to be drawn.
So I have two forms of
electronic conduction.
I have electrons moving to the
left in the conduction band
and I have holes moving to the
right in the valence band.
So for every thermal excitation
I get two carriers.
Every excitation of electron
from valence band to
conduction band generates
two carriers.
Carriers of what?
Water?
Carriers of electrical charge.
Two carriers of electrical
charge.
And what are they?
The electron in the conduction
band and the hole--
little h with a plus sign--
in the valence band.
So that's how thermal
excitation works.
And you can see that the numbers
have to be equal.
So we write, therefore, that
the populations are equal.
The number of electrons in the
conduction band equals the
number of holes in
the valence band.
Now electrical engineers have a
similar expression, but they
don't care about numbers and
electrons and holes, they care
about the functionality.
And the electron is a carrier
of negative charge and the
hole is a carrier of
positive charge.
So the electrical engineering
books will write, thermal
excitation gives rise
to pair generation.
Pair of what?
Pair of charge carriers.
And the population of negative
charge carriers equals the
population of positive charge
carriers, which in chemistry
is the number of electrons
equals the number of holes, or
the number of broken bonds.
So that's the way it works, but
there's a conundrum here.
Thermal excitation is based upon
the thermal energy, and
we know that the average
thermal energy in an
environment is roughly given--
I mean there are fancier
calculations--
but to a first order, I can
approximate it as the product
of the Boltzmann constant and
absolute temperature.
So at room temperature--
room temperature, I like to
say, about 300 Kelvin.
300 Kelvin is 27 Celsius.
That's kind of a warm room,
but 300 is a nice number.
All right?
So if you take 300 Kelvin, you
get on the order of about 1/40
of an electron volt.
1/40 of an electron volt, which
is a lot less than one
electron volt, which is roughly
the band gap of a
semiconductor.
So how is it that we get any
thermal excitation of data
indicate that there is some
thermal excitation even at
room temperature?
So the question is, if the
average thermal energy is a
fortieth of electron volt
according to this-- and this
is correct--
and the band gap is one eV, then
it should be no thermal
excitation.
But we know what happens.
So, one eV, which I'm
going to say is Eg.
All right?
So how do we get any thermal
excitation under these
conditions?
So there's an answer to this.
And for this we go to merry old
England and James Clerk
Maxwell, that you know or will
come to know in 8.02 as the
annunciator of Maxwell's
equations of
electricity and magnetism.
He also thought about physical
chemistry, and in particular
he thought about the physical
chemistry of gases.
And what did he teach
us about gases?
He said, if you look here in
this room, you see nitrogen
and oxygen and all the other
constituents of air.
But to a first approximation,
we have four parts nitrogen,
one part oxygen.
The room is roughly
300 Kelvin.
What Maxwell taught us is that
velocities of the gas species
zooming around in this room
are not all equal.
Some of the gas species are
moving around as though
they're at 500 Kelvin.
And some of them are moving
around very slowly as though
they're at 100 Kelvin.
On average, it's 300 Kelvin,
because we can
feel it as 300 Kelvin.
But some of them are
zooming around.
Some are really lazy and they're
just moving along
really slowly.
And furthermore, he was
quantitative about it.
He said, I'm going to tell you
what the distribution of
energies is.
So let's get that on the
board for starters.
That in any ensemble of gas
species, could be gas atoms or
it could be gas molecules or gas
compounds, in any ensemble
of gas species, that
all molecules--
because you can always say the
atom is a degenerate form--
all molecules do not have
the same velocity.
And furthermore, he gave
us the distribution.
He calculated the distribution
of velocities.
So that was about 1859.
Forgive me here.
Velocities.
OK.
And then Boltzmann came
along in 1872.
And Boltzmann generalized
this idea.
He made the link between gas
velocity and temperature.
So, he took the idea and he
said, if the gas molecules
move at different velocities,
that means they
have different energies.
And why do we call this the
Boltzmann constant?
Because Boltzmann made the link
between particle energy
and temperature.
So he said there's a variation
of instant temperature.
All right?
So Boltzmann generalized
Maxwell's idea to energy and
then ultimately temperature.
And so I'm going to show you,
instead of the Maxwell
distribution, I'm going to give
you the Maxwell-Boltzmann
distribution.
But before I do, I want to make
sure you understand the
math and appreciate what I'm
going to plot for you.
So we just had a test, right?
In fact, we can go back
to the slide.
All right.
So what do we have here?
I could plot on this axis,
the abscissa, the grade--
g--
and on the ordinate, I'll plot
the number of people who have
any given grade--
n of g.
Now the class av was
66, all right?
This is going to go
from 0 to 100.
Now what we see here is-- and
by the way, I'm going to
normalize it.
Instead of dealing with 463 or
whatever, I'm going to divide
by the total class.
So the number is going
to go from 0 to 1.
So this a normalized
distribution.
What I'm teaching you applies
all through science.
As I told you, this is the
most important class.
Not because I'm teaching, but
because the subject matter is
general, just as
Boltzmann did.
So let's look at the normalized
distribution.
Now the class av was 66.
Now we didn't have everybody
getting 66.
That was not the distribution.
That's one solution to the
problem, isn't it?
Instead, what we got
was we got that.
Now one possibility
would be this one,
the bell-shaped curve.
Goes like this.
That's bell-shaped.
This is Gaussian.
This is a Gaussian distribution,
and its
functionality is y equals e to
the minus x minus x average,
quantity squared.
Now, to have a normal
distribution, you have to have
a class of normal people, so
that didn't happen on this
test. That's a joke.
God, you're so serious.
Have you no fun in your lives?
Have you ever laughed?
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: Overachievers, you.
OK.
So we're not going to have
a Gaussian distribution.
We're going to have
that one there.
It's kind of a skewed Gaussian
with a long tail.
All right, so that's
the one thing.
But what Boltzmann gave us,
instead of the number of atoms
of a given grade, he plotted
it as a function of energy.
So instead, the
Maxwell-Boltzmann distribution
has energy as the ordinate
instead of the grade, and up
here, the number of atoms--
or more importantly--
the atom fraction.
The fraction of atoms
in the distribution
that have that energy.
And it doesn't look like
a normal distribution.
It looks sort of off-normal.
Skewed, like this.
It rises to a peak and it
has a long tail that
moves off to the right.
So this is the Maxwell-Boltzmann
distribution.
It's not y equals x minus
x bar squared.
So this is Maxwell-Boltzmann
distribution of energies.
And furthermore, what we see
here is that the area under
this line has to equal 1.
If you integrate the fraction
from 0 to infinity, because
this asymptotically goes out
to infinity, the integral
under this line is 1.
OK.
Area equals 1, which is
the integral of ndE.
Now, because of the asymmetry
here, clearly this is the
average energy.
The average energy isn't
the maximum energy.
Whereas in the Gaussian--
let's keep the Gaussian over
here, just for grins and
chuckles-- so the Gaussian
looks like this.
It's symmetric.
And this is the n of g max and
also a g average, whereas
here, the average is a little
bit to the right.
A little bit higher.
OK.
So now, if this is the
distribution, and this at room
temperature is 1/40 of an
electron volt, and way, way up
here is the band gap energy,
there's a tiny but non-zero
fraction of this distribution
that has energy in excess of
the band gap energy.
And so this tiny fraction of the
total distribution has the
thermal energy to allow this
excitation and pair
generation to occur.
And furthermore, this is a
function of temperature.
This is a function
of temperature.
So E average is related
to temperature.
So, I'll say E average
1 at T1.
And then what I'm going to do is
I'm going to heat this to a
higher temperature, so
I'll use red chalk to
indicate it's hotter.
And what happens to the
distribution under an increase
in temperature?
Well, the average had better
move to the right, and that's
what happens.
But it doesn't just move to the
right, it skews a little
bit and broadens.
So in point of fact, at
a higher temperature,
it looks like this.
OK.
So this is now E average
2 at T2 where T2 is
greater than T1.
T2 is greater than T1.
OK, so that's the
Maxwell-Boltzmann
distribution.
But here's where the interesting
stuff occurs.
So I'm going to blow up this
high energy end of the
distribution.
So again, this is going
to be n of E
normalized, and this is E.
And what we're going to find
here is that at T1--
this is the curve at T1, and
the area under the line is
shown here--
and then--
not to scale--
we're going to put
a break in this.
And I'll show you how much
of a break is needed.
And then, at T2 I'm going
to have this come down.
This is T2.
And the area under the
line T2 captures the
T1 plus all of this.
And so what we see, is that
for a modest increase in
temperature, this maximum shifts
modestly, but the area
under the line in excess
of this critical
energy increases radically.
And that's the powerful
leveraging factor of increase
in temperature.
And I've done some calculations
just to show you
what this does.
The functionality of the
Maxwell-Boltzmann distribution
is e to the minus some critical
energy divided by the
product of Boltzmann constant
temperature.
So we can put in a
value here-- eg--
what have you.
All right.
So I chose for silicon--
for silicon, I know the band
gap energy is 1.1 eV--
and I have it at room
temperature--
when I go through the
calculation--
the fraction underneath that
line is 10 to the minus 19.
One part in 10 to
the minus 19.
This is the area.
Area under the curve is greater
than the band gap
energy of 1.1 eV.
So then I said, let's go up
to the melting point.
I'm not going to melt the
silicon, I'm just going to
bring it up to its melting
point but not melt it.
So it's like ice cubes
at 0 Celsius.
It's still solid.
OK?
The melting point of silicon,
you can look in your Periodic
Table, it's over
1400 degrees C.
And this is 10 to the minus 4.
10 to the minus 4.
Area under curve: da da da da.
So that means that
the red area--
A2, the red.
Actually, let's use red chalk so
that everybody is in tune.
A2 to A1 is equal to 10 to the
15, whereas T2 over T1--
well, red chalk.
It's my chance to use red chalk
and I'm not going to
squander it.
T2 divided by T1--
it's about 1700 Kelvin divided
by 300 Kelvin--
is about 6.
So for a change in temperature
by a factor of 6, I get a
change in population
of 10 to the 15.
So you can see how modest
increases in temperature have
a huge impact on thermal
excitation.
So now you say, if we wanted
to make a device, we can't
heat our computers up to 1600
degrees, 1500 degrees C in
order to get an adequate number
of charge carriers.
There has to be another way
to get charge carriers.
I'm going to show you
a third way that's
called chemical promotion.
So now I want to talk about
charge carrier generation.
Charge carrier generation by
change of chemistry, and it's
going to be specifically
by the introduction of
impurities.
Charge carrier generation by
introduction of impurities.
You might say, gee, aren't
impurities bad for a system?
Well, I want to tell you,
there are two kinds of
impurities in this world.
There are bad impurities which
we call contaminants, and
that's what you're commonly
taught to think about.
That's bad.
But there are good impurities,
and these are called dopants.
Dopants are impurities
that we are happy
to have in our system.
And so by the introduction of
impurities of value, we can
lead to engineered materials.
So I'm giving you the
introduction to high
technology, where we're going
to control the engineering
properties of a material through
control of chemistry.
So that's chemical composition
tailored--
for specific--
for targeted values
of properties.
And that's the essence
of material science.
We control the chemistry.
We control the properties by
controlling the chemistry.
So what I want to do is give a
vivid example of this, and
it's not going to be an
isolated example.
It's going to be the example
that pertains to all of the
microelectronic devices
in our world.
So that's silicon.
So let's look at how doping
works in silicon.
It also applies to germanium,
but we don't use much
germanium in devices.
It's dominantly silicon.
So what we're going
to do is dope.
The gambit here is to dope--
that's introduce an impurity--
with aliovalent impurity.
What do I mean by aliovalent?
You know the word alias?
It's another name.
Alio in Latin means other.
So we're going to dope silicon
with something that has a
different valence from
that of silicon.
Can't before.
So let's look at the
simplest example.
And I'm going to put phosphorus
into silicon.
I'm going to dope phosphorus
into silicon, and phosphorus
is Group 5, or more properly,
IUPAC calls it Group 15.
So we're going to put Group 15
element into silicon, which is
Group 14 element.
So we call phosphorus a
supervalent dopant, meaning it
has a valence higher than
that of the silicon.
So it's a supervalent dopant.
Supervalent dopant.
So now let's look at how that
supervalent dopant works.
I'm going to show you some
silicon here, and I'm going to
give you the silicon.
This is sp3 hybridized.
it's sitting here as
a single crystal.
Here are three silicons.
So it's a single crystal.
All these silicons on the
bottom row line up.
All the silicons in the
center line up.
And there are silicons at the
top and they all line up.
So that if I look at it on the
edge, it's a perfectly,
atomically smooth system.
And I have one of these.
I know Professor Ballinger made
reference to it last day.
This is last-generation
technology.
It's only eight-inch diameter.
But this is an eight-inch
diameter silicon wafer.
So this started as a giant
salami, eight inches in
diameter-- probably
two meters long.
Single crystal.
Every atom here is adjacent to
the next atom according to the
rules of atomic arrangement.
And when this thing is
cut and polished,
it's flat to one atom.
It is atomically flat.
And it makes a fantastic
shaving mirror.
Actually Dave, can
you cut to this?
Yeah, here we go.
Here's the penny.
And this is silicon here.
It's going to drive this thing
nuts because it can't focus on
this thing, because it's so--
there we are.
So this was a part of a giant
salami, and now it's been cut.
And obviously you can't
cut it one-atom thick.
It's some submillimeter
thickness, because you need to
have some mechanical
strength to it.
But the surface is absolutely
flat to one atom.
All right.
And that's what we're
going to dope into.
We're going to dope into this
thing, and I'll show you how
we're going to dope it later.
Actually, why don't
we cut to that.
Here's something that's already
been doped and made
into devices.
So there's the plain old
silicon, which you're having a
hard time seeing anything
except a little bit of
reflection.
And now here's the thing that's
been processed, so
let's zoom.
Zoom.
OK.
So now you can see
all the features.
So these features involved gas
phase reaction to introduce
dopant atoms into the
silicon lattice.
And then we're going to chop
these little things up and put
them in your cell phones and in
your laptops and whatever
other devices are out there.
OK.
So this is what we're talking
about, and if we live long
enough, we'll see
one of these.
This is a Pentium chip.
OK.
So where's the chip?
The chip is underneath
this piece of gold.
Where did I put my pointer?
Ah, it's over here.
All right.
So the actual silicon device
is underneath this.
And all of these are this
spider's web of leads.
It's trying to access all
the tiny devices.
It doesn't do you any good to
have a device density that's
greater than your
access density.
So the technology that goes
into this is phenomenal.
Plus, these things all
generate heat.
When you put all these tens of
thousands of devices into
something the size of your
fingernail, you've got a
toaster oven working here, and
you have to get that heat out.
And this is several
generations old.
What you have in your
machines today is
even denser than this.
And supercomputers?
Forget it.
You have to have those things so
aggressively cooled or else
they'll heat up and it'll
be just like a
light bulb, just bursting.
So that's what's going
on inside.
So let's see how that happens.
Let's cut back to-- well,
you can leave that up.
It's a pretty image and will
probably soothe the nerves of
the students.
So now I'm going to put
phosphorus in here.
I'll put phosphorus in here, but
where does phosphorus go?
Phosphorus goes onto
a silicon site.
So it actually comes
in and sits here.
Phosphorus comes and sits
at a silicon site.
Now what do we know about
the number of bonds that
phosphorus likes to form?
It has five valence electrons.
So it forms one, two, three,
four bonds, and
it has a fifth electron.
And that fifth electron is
sitting there somewhere.
It's sitting there somewhere
in the lattice.
All right.
It's sitting somewhere in the
lattice because it has no
place to go.
Now in energy space, I
know where it goes.
So here's the conduction band
of silicon, and this is the
valence band.
And this is all of the silicon
host crystal, because the
dopant is in a tiny,
tiny amount.
We're talking parts
per million.
So for all intents and
purposes, it's
still a silicon crystal.
It has tiny amounts of
phosphorus in it.
So this is the band gap of
silicon, where this is about
1.1 electron volts.
And where does this
fifth electron go?
This fifth electron sits up in
here in the conduction band,
doesn't it?
And every time I introduce a
phosphorus, I have a fifth
electron that goes in
the conduction band.
But I don't have to
generate a hole.
I don't need to break bonds in
order to put electrons in the
conduction band.
Because the fifth electron
is like the fifth wheel.
You know?
It goes in the conduction
band.
So there's no generation
of holes here.
All right.
And furthermore, I can control
the conductivity.
At the end of last lecture,
Professor Ballinger showed you
that the conductivity of a
substance is related to the
number of charge carriers.
So if I want to double the
number of phosphoruses, I will
double the number of electrons
in the conduction band,
independent of temperature.
All right.
So for every phosphorus dopant
atom, we get one electron in
the conduction band.
We get one electron in the
conduction band and no holes.
No holes in the valence band.
It's direct.
All right.
Now, electrical engineers would
look at this and they'd
say, I don't care if
it's phosphorus.
They don't care about the
chemistry, they care about the
functionality.
What kind of carriers am I
throwing into this crystal?
For an electrical engineer,
there are only
two kinds of carriers.
Positive carriers and
negative carriers.
For every phosphorus,
what's the outcome?
A negative carrier.
So this is now doped silicon.
It generated negative
carriers, so
this is called n-type.
This is now n-type silicon.
And its properties are governed
by the population of
these-- because I'm going to
show you in a second that the
number of these far exceeds the
number that are thermally
generated--
so the properties here
are called extrinsic.
So now we have a crystal that
is exhibiting it's extrinsic
behavior, thanks to the doping
with the supervalent impurity.
One more thing.
Something very, very
cool here.
You see this electron?
It's sitting here somewhere
in the--
now this is Cartesian map.
I'm looking through a scanning
electron microscope.
I see all the silicons.
I get the phosphorus.
And there's an electron
in here somewhere.
And this has 15, right?
This has 15 protons.
This has 14 protons.
So in a land of 14 plus,
15 plus is relatively
positive, isn't it?
The phosphorus is locally
positive in comparison with
the rest of the silicon
lattice.
And it's pinned, because
it's covalently bonded.
And there's an electron
sitting here
with no place to go.
Do you know of a model that
describes the behavior of a
one-electron system around a
pinned positive nucleus?
AUDIENCE: The Bohr model.
PROFESSOR: Bohr model?
Just for grins and chuckles,
what if we were to use the
Bohr model to describe the
behavior of that electron?
You can say it's crazy.
That doesn't make any sense,
because that's not a
one-electron system.
But what if we modeled
it as though it were?
I'm going to-- just for grins
and chuckles-- get a sense of
what that ground
state value is.
And recall that in hydrogen,
the ground state--
E1, ground state of
the electron--
is equal to minus k.
Which is minus me to the fourth
over 8 epsilon naught
squared times Planck
constant squared.
Which is minus 13.6
electron volts
So what is the energy of that
electron there if we use the
Bohr model?
Well, we have to modify it
a little bit, because the
electron isn't moving
in a vacuum.
Depending on how far this
electron is from the center,
it could be moving around, and
there are all kinds of silicon
atoms and bonds and whatnot.
So there are all kinds of stuff
between the electron and
the center here.
So I have to use a
modified form.
I don't use the permittivity
of vacuum.
I map the permittivity
of vacuum into
the dielectric constant.
This is the dielectric
constant of silicon.
Remember there's so little
phosphorus there that it
doesn't alter the properties.
And then for reasons I can't
go in to here, I have to
change the mass of
the electron into
the effective mass--
we saw this when Bohr did the
calculation about the lines of
helium plus--
effective mass of electron
in the conduction band.
So if you put both
of those in--
and I've got numbers
for this--
this value is 11.7 and the
second one is about 1/5 of the
rest mass of the electron.
So if you put all of that in,
you end up with the energy of
this ground state electron equal
to minus k times 0.2
divided by 11.7 squared,
which equals minus
0.02 electron volts.
So this is 2/100 of an electron
volt below something.
What's it below?
It's below the conduction
band.
It's right here.
This is the ground state of the
electron from phosphorus.
It's the ground state of the
E1 of electron from
phosphorus.
And phosphorus, the electrical
engineers call a donor.
A donor of what?
It's a donor of electrons.
So this thing here is called
the donor level.
And that's the ground state.
So the electron should
be sitting.
Isn't the ground state here
lower than the bottom of the
conduction band?
Sure it is.
So the electron really should
be down in here.
There's the electron.
Now you're saying, how are you
going to get conductivity?
Well, we just figured out that
the energy level of the ground
state of the donor--
so I'm going to call this the
energy of the donor level,
ground state--
is 0.02.
How does that compare with
thermal energy at room
temperature?
It's comparable.
So at room temperature with
1/40 of an electron volt,
there's enough energy to promote
this electron up into
the conduction band by
thermal excitation
from the donor level.
Thermal excitation from
the donor level.
And in fact, if we want to do
something really, really--
I want to use an adverb here--
really, really cool.
If that's the ground state--
I'm going to blow this up.
So this is the bottom of
the conduction band.
And now this is the
ground state.
This is the donor level.
This is the donor level,
which I was calling E1.
Is it just the donor level here
and the conduction band,
or can you see that there's
an E2 and an E3 and an E4?
And I have a whole set of
quantum states from the donor
level right up to the
conduction band.
And if I have enough energy--
if E thermal is on the
order of E donor--
I get promotion of
these up in here.
Now what would we say if this
were the Bohr model?
You'd have an electron loose in
a ground state up in here
where it's free to move.
What's that process called?
Ionization.
And you know what the electrical
engineers call
these electrons?
They call them ionized
electrons.
But they're referring to the
ionization of the electron out
of the donor level into the
conduction band, not out of
the silicon crystal.
So these are ionized electrons
out of donor level.
So we've come full circle.
By the way, this is
a calculation.
You know what the measured
value is?
It was measured as minus
0.045 electron volts.
You might look at that and say,
whoa, that's about two
times this.
Hey, wait a minute.
We started at 13.6.
We went from 13.6 to this, and
the real value is this, and so
we are in good shape.
Now, what happens if I put
another phosphorus in here?
Another phosphorus, it's also
going to sit at this--
I'm going to do it over here.
If I put another phosphorus,
it also has
the same donor level.
And another phosphorus, it
has the same donor level.
How can I justify this?
Am I not violating the Pauli
exclusion principle?
How come all the phosphorus
donor states
are at the same level?
Or put another way, under
what circumstances is
this diagram accurate?
If the number of phosphorus
atoms that I
introduce is tiny--
parts per million--
the separation, the physical
separation of this phosphorus
from its nearest phosphorus
neighbor is so great, that for
all intents and purposes, they
are at infinite separation.
And therefore, all of the
phosphorus donor atoms
establish a donor level
at the same value.
And if you dope to very, very
high levels, you see this
break down.
If you go to very, very high
concentrations of phosphorus
dopant, you will discover what
happens if these two energy
levels get close enough together
in real space.
They have to split.
And so you'll see all of that
happening down here at the
miniature level.
The last thing I wanted to do
was to push the Bohr model
just a little bit harder.
And so I've given you an energy,
and the energy seems
to make sense.
Even though you might say,
this is the crazy.
It's not a one-electron system,
but it gave us a
reasonable number.
Let's just for interest's sake
determine: what's this radius?
I wonder how far this electron
is away from the donor
phosphorus?
So I plug into the r1.
That's the radius of the
ground state electron.
And that's the Bohr
radius, right?
0.529 angstroms in elemental
hydrogen, but now this has to
be modified by adding the
dielectric constant and the
effective mass.
And the number is 30 angstroms,
or 3 nanometers, if
you must. All right?
And compare that to
silicon-silicon bond distance.
The silicon-silicon bond
distance is 2.35 angstroms. So
clearly this electron is very
far removed from the central
phosphorus.
It's not as I depicted.
It has to be way over here,
going way, way around.
This is really, really
something.
So now you understand how you
can get extrinsic properties
and the behavior of the system
governed by the introduction
of impurities.
What I'm going to do next day,
is to show you that at typical
doping levels, when you
dope, dope at about 10
to the minus 6--
1 part per million--
10 to the minus 6 phosphorus
per silicon.
It turns out that the number
of electrons from this
operation is much greater than
the number of electrons from
thermal excitation,
which is tiny.
And therefore, we argue that the
properties are governed by
the dopant atom, and so
we have extrinsic
behavior that we see.
OK, well that's a day's work.
David, may we go to the
slides, please?
OK, so you saw all that last
day, and this, this, this.
All right, there's the
insulator, and that.
So I'm just doing the lecture
again and fast. You can read.
You can parse visual images.
See?
There's the n-type
semiconductor.
We're going to look at p-type
next day, quickly.
There's a silicon crystal.
There's the salamis--
there's the little wafers
that are cut.
And there's the spectrum, the
x-ray spectrum indicating you
have a single crystal.
There's the first transistor--
this was a single crystal
of germanium
lying here on its side--
the point transistor in
the fall of 1947.
Three gentleman at the Bell
Labs that demonstrated the
rectification.
And they won the Nobel Prize
for this in 1956.
Now, you can also make
semiconductors that have compounds.
So these are compound
semiconductors--
Professor Ballinger showed you
last day-- tin, germanium,
silicon, carbon.
And look at all of these.
This is a Group 3 element
with a Group 5 element.
5 plus 3 is 8.
Group 3 and 5.
This is Group 2 and 6.
2 plus 6 is 8.
It's always about
octet stability.
But they make strong covalent
bonds that give band gaps all
over the map.
So suppose I wanted to have
something like a stoplight.
Suppose I wanted a stoplight,
and I wanted
to make a red light.
Well, I need--
I can go backwards from 660
nanometers, and I can go e
equals hc over lambda
and calculate--
I need a material with 1.97
electron volts band gap, and I
look on here and there's nothing
that's exactly 1.97.
Well, I can mix these things.
I can mix them.
I can mix something that has
1.52 with 2.3 and get 1.97.
That's called band
gap engineering.
And there's more than one mix
here, so why would I choose
one mix over another?
It's cheaper, or it's easier to
process, or it's stable in
the atmosphere.
You don't want a semiconductor
that can't
stand rain and snow.
And so I'm showing you here
a variety of compound
semiconductors, and this is
the basis of things like--
the LED, the CD reader, the DVD
reader is based on light
that's generated from these.
What was the big deal
about Blu-ray?
Why is Blu-ray so cool?
Because the original
reader was red.
And what's the wavelength
of red light?
Red light is around
600 nanometers.
And what's the wavelength
of blue light?
It's down around
300 nanometers.
So all other things being equal,
my stylus is half the
size, which means for a given
area, I can get double the
density of information without
changing the size of the disc.
But it wasn't trivial to
find a blue laser.
And the person who found the
right mix of compounds that
could give blue in an efficient
manner became a very
wealthy individual.
So this is our stoplight now.
These are the materials that
go into the stoplights.
No more do you have that giant
lens with a 150-watt
incandescent bulb.
Now you have the array of these
LEDs that are designed
to be in this band gap.
So I think at this point, we've
probably run out of time.
So we'll resume the discussion
tomorrow.
Same time, same place.